okay this
kazushi continues to leave most of you
um you're not
bending them at the waist and then
bending them at the waist and bending
him over
you are tilting him
then turning him
tilting him and then turning them
so if i if he doesn't want me to bend
him at his waist don't let me bend it
you're never going to do it that's why
you use that in your aikido
it's very powerful so you're not going
to
make someone bend backwards he doesn't
want me to
i'm not going to do it but i can't tilt
him
then i can turn him
and even someone who does not lock their
center when they're coming in
with aggressive intention their center
is locked
so even if he
didn't care if i bend me his sincere
aggression would not allow him to break
at the waist
secondly never check someone
and then uncheck him even if you could
bend him at the waist
that is not marshall if you got the
first check
you keep the first check you'll
uncheck him to throw him
so don't bring this down
tilt him tilt him
boom tilt
thirdly if he's still going forward
or staying still until i enter
i have to be strong enough to overcome
that mass
when that's not what we're doing that's
not jiu jitsu that's
not aikido so when i tilt him
he's already falling that way
just like this i'm here i tilt him he's
already falling that way
i just aim it so he's
coming in i tilt him he's already
falling that way i'm just aiming that
so if he's standing still you're right
over here yeah
you could that's not aikido
i don't want that
oh i'm staying with him
no no no tilt him
oh you're falling
[Music]
just like this one
he's already falling
i need her to stay with him
and to aim him in turn
he's already falling stay with him
[Music]
tilt in
[Applause]
[Music]
don't bend your arm right from here
right there go up
don't bend your arm
get a ground path keep going outside
foot ground pops
drop the red hand drop it
[Music]
you